hello well the conservative mp neil
parish has resigned after what he's
called a moment of madness when he
admitted watching pornography twice in
the house of commons well it's certainly
not what conservatives want to be
talking about in the week before those
crucial local elections which after a
pretty rocky few months will undoubtedly
be seen as a test of boris johnson's
leadership and that's not to mention the
cost of living crisis something our next
guest will be acutely aware of he's
urging oil and gas companies to reinvest
the bumper profits they're currently
making to increase investment in the
north sea we can talk now to the
business secretary quasi quatten thank
you very much for being uh with us thank
you sophie um i just want to start off
by talking a bit about the culture in
the house of commons um as we just said
in the introduction more than 50 mps
apparently being investigated for sexual
misconduct of course had the case of the
conservative mp who's admitted watching
pornography twice in the house of
commons is there a culture of misogyny
in parliament i don't think there's a
culture of misogyny i think the problem
we have uh is that people are working in
a really
intense environment
there are long hours
and i think generally most people uh
know their limits they know how to act
respectfully but there are some
instances
where people
don't frankly act
according to the highest standards and
with neil
i think he did the right thing uh he did
something which in most other
professions you would be sacked uh for
doing
and he voluntarily resigned and i think
his position was
uh very difficult
um as you say he has resigned but there
are wider accusations now there's a
wider look at what's going on
in the house of commons uh not just one
person and i just want to read you
something from the sunday times or all
the newspapers that have this kind of
thing this morning but this is from the
sunday times
talking about some of the allegations a
senior mp accused of repeatedly licking
the faces of male researchers other
allegations include staff has been
groped in parliamentary bars by mps
female parliamentarians been subjected
to misogynistic nicknames even claims a
minister overheard having noisy sex in
his office i mean what is going on have
you seen any of this kind of stuff no
i've never seen any of it it is
extraordinary and obviously it's
completely unacceptable
and that's why we've set up only three
years ago
the independent complaints and grievance
scheme
which allows people
to go to an independent body and
complain make complaints make a serious
accusations because i mean when i came
in in 2010 there was none of that there
was no recourse all you could do was
complain uh to the person you're working
for which
in many cases would be the person who
was uh you know behaving badly on that
do you think that's something that
should be changed the speaker's saying
today that he wants to look at the
system where mps directly employ their
own staff because you can see why it'd
be problematic absolutely so so uh as i
said in 2010 we had we didn't have any
recourse at all 2018 we set up this
independent complaints and grievance
scheme which allows people to uh
complain to an independent body and i
think the the speaker and people like
dame andre led some are very good very
clear
that we need to see how we can improve
the current situation to be clear do you
think that
the mps should be able to directly
employ and be responsible for the hr of
their staff well it's not my
view not my opinion uh that matters in
this we've got the speaker we've got
other people who are looking at the best
uh and the best practices
look i think that generally uh most mps
uh
have have a sense of responsibility
um and i've had the same pa for 12 years
and i have a sense of responsibility in
terms of looking after staff in some
instances
i think people
do
act irresponsibly and that's why we've
got this independent uh scheme and it's
only been around for three years it
doesn't sound um
like a short amount of time but it but
it needs
time to really get get get going and
actually it probably needs more
resources as well so you don't have an
opinion then on whether mp should be
able to direct employ staff i take your
point that obviously i'm sure the
majority of mps are fine but the whole
point is that you're looking at the
people who have behaviour responsibly
yeah i'm not going to lurch to one
conclusion or another i think that what
the speaker said yesterday was that we
should look at best practice around the
world so that we can get the best system
so there are lots of different avenues
but clearly what's working uh what we
have now isn't working sufficiently well
um another thing that some people are
talking about is female representation
in the house of commons oliver dowden
the conservative party chair has told
the sunday telegraph he wants to make
sure in his words the party's
candidate's list reflects the fact that
half the population are women would you
like to see 50 conservative women mps i
think we should have certainly a lot
more uh female mps just as we should
have more people from a wider range in
the conservative part in the
conservative party um again we've made
huge progress i mean i remember when i
was on the candidates list in 2003 there
were no ethnic minority conservative mps
um there's been a huge change in that
but clearly uh there's a long way to go
would you like to see all women
shortlists i've never been a fan frankly
personally of um quotas and shortlists
i've never really advocated that but
obviously we should do all we can
to see how we can get more women and
more people from diverse backgrounds
into politics um how about parliament's
bars is it acceptable that there are so
many bars in the house of commons should
they be shut no they shouldn't all be
shut i don't think we should have a kind
of
excessively puritanical or severe regime
in that regard i think again i would say
people should be expected to act uh
responsibly and if they don't uh we've
got we should have the process the
procedure uh to make sure that people
are sanctioned and punished i guess my
issue is listening to you you know you
condemn
some of what's happened
and you say that you know we need to
take action i can't work out what action
you think should be taken uh you know
you won't commit to saying it would be a
good idea to look at how mps employ
their staff you don't want to look at
parliament's bars you don't want all
women's shortlists
so what i actually said
because you were trying to get me to do
uh to advocate one person i'm just
trying to work out what you would like
to change in westminster in order to
stop this kind of thing i think
definitely we should look at um mp's
practices you asked me a specific
question and i said that's what we're
looking into i wasn't going to give you
the answer because that's exactly the
question
that we're examining i think i've never
been a fan of quotas but i think we
should do all we can to encourage more
women uh to come into politics and
people from diverse backgrounds from
diverse professional backgrounds from
diverse uh ethnic backgrounds uh and to
reflect the diversity in our in our
culture okay okay thank you i'm keen to
talk to you about the local elections as
well uh big votes going on of course
across the country next week what would
success look like for the conservative
party well look we're gonna fight for
every vote um clearly in a midterm
situation uh there is a lot of pressure
i'm not going to give a number or or say
anything like that but i think we're
competitive i think i look back at the
2012 local elections which again were
mid midterm very very challenging
frankly at the moment i i think uh you
know we do face challenges but we're in
a reasonable place and i was uh speaking
to uh constituents on friday and i think
i think you know there's all to playful
um you say that there's a challenging uh
situation at the later salvation poll
shows the conservatives on just 34 with
labeling 47 so big gulf fare and that of
course would put some of those key
councils at risk and in places like
wandsworth places like berry some of
these flagship conservative councils are
you worried that you're going to be
punished for when voters look at what's
happening in westminster that you're
going to be punished for that at the
polls in every local election people
vote on a variety of
reasons for a variety of reasons and
sometimes people
look to national politics i think
actually increasingly people do look at
the local uh local situation you've got
labour councils such as croydon uh
nottingham who went bankrupt i think
people are very aware of the fact that
labour is not uh generally a good
custodian of uh public money um and
labour councils have gone bankrupt so
they will people will be voting on local
issues how about in scotland as well do
you think labour could overtake you to
become a second party in scotland i
don't know um about the situation uh in
scotland i mean i do follow scottish
politics very closely but we've been
competitive over the last few years in
scotland we've done very well actually
and i'm hoping that we can continue to
do that so you think you might be able
to hang on to the second place after
that after the snp i hope so i think
that's what we're going to be fighting
for okay now we know of course that some
conservative mps have lost faith in the
leadership of boris johnson because
they've told us that they're the only
ones of course that we know about
because they're the ones that spoken
publicly about it
the local elections next week going to
be seen as a key test for boris
johnson's leadership
if you perform badly
could his leadership be a threat i don't
think his leadership is a threat at all
i mean what he's delivered is really a
remarkable series of successes i think
brexit he delivered on that
i think the fact that he was
uh very widely appreciated in ukraine
he's been widely um held as someone
who's led uh the the ukrainian um effort
the overseas effort to rip to help
ukraine and also look at the vaccine
rollout that was very again a great
great bit of no matter what happens next
week no matter what the results are
boris johnson is safe absolutely you
better tell jeremy hunt according to the
mel on sunday he's about to launch his
leadership well jeremy is a very capable
colleague he's a good friend
i don't know what he's up to but as far
as i'm concerned boris johnson is the
right man uh by far uh to lead us into
the next election are you concerned that
what he's up to might be gunning for the
leadership i don't know what jeremy
you'll have to ask him i don't know what
his plans are and also lots of rumors uh
in westminster and i wouldn't
necessarily believe all of them okay and
now
if it does go badly in the local
elections you talk about the challenging
uh picture uh this may be uh why i just
want to bring you uh this polling from
yougov which i hope hopefully we should
be able to see so they people were asked
which government would be better at
regenerating areas outside of london and
the southeast
17 percent
said the conservatives in boris johnson
38 said labour in kirsten like your
flagship policy is literally to level up
and people just don't believe you're
gonna do it well it's one poll
and that's why we're going out uh to
make the message clearer
uh and more focused and i think
absolutely if you look at what we're
doing if you look at somewhere uh like
uh ben hodgson's uh mayoralty in the
northeast uh t side there's huge amounts
of investment billions of investment uh
nissan who told us uh
they were reported to say that we were
they were gonna leave uh the uk after
the brexit vote they've invested a
billion pounds they've announced they're
going to invest a billion pounds you
accept that the messaging needs to be
clearer and more focused do you i think
i think i think we're absolutely always
trying to make our message clearer and
more focused and we have uh a number of
uh months
to do that ahead of uh any prospective
future election we're absolutely focused
to get the message out there and the
results are pretty tangible i mean you
know as i said billion pounds from
nissan we've got british volts who are
making um uh batteries for electric
vehicles they've announced up to two and
a half billion pounds in blind these are
important numbers sophie this is a this
is really happening people are actually
looking at an economy that's creating
jobs they're very very uh pleased about
that they're looking at the economy and
worried about their own budgets as well
aren't they looking at inflation at
seven percent they're worried about how
they're going to pay their energy bills
absolutely when are you going to come
back with an emergency budget there
won't be an emergency budget uh
obviously that's something uh for the
chancellor but he's rolling out no
matter what i'm not really it's not in
my power to do that you know as well as
i do many of your viewers that budgets
are for the for the for the chancellor
all i'm saying is that there's been
considerable amount of support already
he's had a 9.1 billion uh package at the
beginning of this year uh and in the
spring statement there was also a
further five billion up to five billion
pounds uh to support uh the most
vulnerable uh customers and to support
people precisely uh to deal with the
cost of living so no need for an
emergency budget then it's up to the
chancellor of exchequer that's his uh
that's his job uh your job is energy of
course and business so you're urging uh
oil and gas companies to increase the
investment in the north sea what's the
idea well the idea there is that um they
they're going to be announcing profits
uh they're successful companies and i'm
saying to them you know it's it's great
that you are your british companies
you're successful uh british companies
but it's absolutely vital that you
reinvest uh in in britain particularly
in gas so that we have energy security
but also without gas we're not going to
get the new technologies we're not going
to get uh blue hydrogen what they call
blue hydrogen we're not going to be able
to do carbon capture which is a key part
of of the new uh greener economy and
what happens if they just ignore you and
will you impose a windfall tax on them
well i've never been
a supporter of winfield texas i've been
very clear about that publicly i think
that that discourages investment and the
reason why we want to have investment is
because it creates jobs it creates
wealth and it also gives us energy
security so
it's vital that companies invest in the
uk and actually to be fair are you on
the same page as a chancellor on that
the reason i ask is rishi sunak said to
mumsnet this week in talking about the
windfall tax what i would say is that if
we don't see that type of investment
coming forward and companies are not
going to make those investments in our
country in energy security then of
course that's something i would look at
and nothing is ever off the table in
these things so he's a chance of the
exchequer he's responsible for tax
policy from my point of view i want to
see investment in the north sea i really
want to see
these assets developed and also driving
new technologies which are going to
green
our economy which are going to reduce
carbon emissions
technologies like carbon capture and in
order to get that going in order to get
jobs in order to get people
working in these exciting new
technologies we need investment and that
investment is going to come from the
private sector it sounds like you want
to rule out the win either of a windfall
tax but the chancellor
doesn't want to do that my own view is
that and i've said this publicly many
times
a windfall tax will act as a
disincentive
uh to to invest and we want to see
investment we want to see developing our
own assets and not only for jobs but for
energy security okay uh thank you very
much uh for being on the program thank
you
thank you